yoga and meditation inform your diet
because it's mindfulness and when you
are awake and aware of what's going on
you you obviously make better choices
and certainly you know you can feel if
you're sensitive I mean you your
physical asana practice or the entire
spiritual yoga practice informs how you
relate to the world I mean the first
thing in yoga in the eight parts of yoga
is ahimsa non-harming and no one would
good sense or no one who's aware of
their footprint would ever eat an animal
and under these circumstances they would
not contribute to the abuse of a hundred
billion animals you know per year a
hundred billion is the worst karmic
disaster in the world I mean the
absolute abuse I mean born into a life a
short life of extreme suffering only to
poison the individual and destroy the
planet is there no one would want to no
one who practice to himsa which is the
first to the Yama's would ever
participate in that if he was aware and
then meditation because mindfulness as
well as you know mindfulness come from
the physical asana or the yoga practice
overall but no one who's aware and gave
any thought to or just came from you
know what's edged inside them his
spiritual or this peace of God that's
etched inside them this thing would
inform them if they sat stillness made
their own decisions they wouldn't do it
so your diet would change do you know
that fifty percent of african-american
women over 20 have some form of heart
disease then all the bad cholesterol
every single bit of it comes from animal
product I mean why you know when there's
so many alternatives that are better
that are cheaper it just makes good
sense to move away from animal product
to a plant-based diet and and talk about
climate change right and everybody's
discussing climate change and
never mentioned the greatest cause of
global warming the abuse of these
animals destruction of all the resources
on the planet and the plant itself the
the the cows alone are more destructive
to the planet then all the trains planes
and automobiles and boats put together
almost times - so why not mention that
when we discuss climate change and I
think people just have to make a choice
but also it's why we went back you go
back to the meditation thing you
meditate so you can be present and aware
you know you don't have to have to pass
inform your future since the past and
the future will never be here all you
have to do is just a second of presence
and you can change on a dime the past
and the print in the future just the
imagination that never comes so it's if
you are present even in a second of
presence you can shift your life you
don't have to carry the weight or the
burden of what's been forced on you or
what mistakes you've made or you can
just be present and and operate from a
really free space